let's go ahead and get started because I
really
um I'm excited about this show and you
know when I hear your name
um certain things come to my mind right
you know fabulous of course
um gorgeous obviously badass you know no
Bill's one of the favorites
um and also my favorite episode of
Living Single I love that so that you're
in
um uh with the Heavy D
um so but I'm now excited I can add True
Crime to this list uh so can you tell me
about how you got involved with the
interrogation room wow it was actually a
direct offer
um film rise contacted my agent said
we're doing a new show and there's only
one person that we thought of to host
the show and it's Vivica A fox
um can you see if she would be
interested in hosting the show I played
a detective before I played a detective
on Lifetime for many years on the show
Missy so I said absolutely they flew me
to London and we take the two the ten
episodes wow yeah and I did notice some
British accents in there you know that's
what some British accents with the uh
the uh folks explaining the
um body language
um that's a really cool aspect of it you
mentioned early on you know talking
about as an actor you know you have to
understand body language and portray
different things
into the show
um could you speak a little more on that
absolutely I think that is the one thing
that I learned
um
hosting the show because not only did I
host the show I also had to do the
narration for the show so when we first
delivered
um uh the tape the shows for me it was
like hosting you know I'm really good
with the teleprompter but then when we
went to do the narration of the show we
got to see the actual foot I got to see
the actual footage and so oh my gosh a
lot of times it really tugged at my
heartstrings you know like the first
episode of the little eight-year-old
girl that disappears oh my gosh that
really really stuck with me a lot so
um but I did learn a lot from the
investigators how they moved in
um I loved when they let people marinate
where they would go offer them something
to drink and then come back and be like
hey would you like to tell me something
else have you been thinking because when
they leave the people always forget that
they're still being filmed so it was a
lot for me to learn but I've had a
couple people ask me well can you tell
when your man is lying and I said I
don't know about all that
learn a lot from watching the show
amazing amazing um what has been the
most interesting case so far are you
allowed to share that well The
Disappearance of the eight-year-old girl
was the one that really tugged at my
heartstrings however there was a case of
um the African-American teenager riding
in the car with his friends and he was
the car was shot at because they were
playing the music just a tad bit too
loud and then how afterwards the
gentleman just went home and I'm not
even gonna call him a gentleman the
perpetrator went home and had a bottle
of wine and ate some pizza like no big
deal uh that one just really bothered to
especially when you listen to the
father's testimony where it's like I
won't get to see him graduate I won't
get to see him get married have his
first child and but what I love about
this show the interrogation room is that
it gets Justice and also visibility for
crimes that are committed
um it kind of gets um
you know when when the family
um not only gets Justice for them but
exposure so it kind of gets them
um I guess a little bit of finality in
it like to get closure that's the word I
was looking for gets them closure on it
they know who did it that they've been
prosecuted and that justice has been
served absolutely that's that's amazing
to to be able to watch that unfold and
see how it happens now another question
I have is you know the show's main focus
is on those tactics right those
interrogation practices that they use in
the room there are lots of instances of
coerced confessions is that something
that the show will ever address well in
the 10 episodes I can honestly say no
because that never happened we got some
straight up investigators that are doing
um right by the law and and I think that
that's important as well to see
especially in now in cases nowadays
where we have coerced confessions and
police brutality going on that it's good
to see a positive aspect of law
enforcement absolutely absolutely now
that makes a lot of sense we do want to
see the good side uh yeah
I think that that's the only thing that
you may have the good cop bad cop when
they're trying to get a confession that
you got one guy that's you know playing
it one way and another guy playing it
another way but overall it's a team
effort absolutely
um well I do want to also chat with you
about some other stuff that you know you
are you are Vivica A fox okay you are an
actress you're so much more than an
actress though too you're an author uh
yes you're an entrepreneur director
director yes everything I almost started
singing with uh Chaka Khan but we're not
gonna do that
um so uh can you tell me more about your
off-screen endeavors oh my gosh my
off-screen Endeavors will have the
Vivica A fox hair collection
um yes that I've been doing for 16 years
can you believe that wow yes and soon I
might be able to share a little surprise
with you all when it comes to Fashion so
stay tuned for that stay tuned for that
I know I had foxy breed but I have a new
wonderful Adventure that we're in the
prospect of closing the deals um I have
a lifetime Christmas movie that's going
to be coming out and then I also just
did a film directed by my Empire nephew
Jesse Smalley and then we have the first
lady of Black Mafia Family the Tanisha
Waltz store which I directed
yes yes so I've been a very busy and
blessed bee lately absolutely that's
wonderful
um congratulations on that I'm excited
is so is this your directorial debut or
I can't recall trust the sandalwood from
Megamind media she had me do a short uh
for bet plus uh women's month where we
deal with social issues that we don't
like to talk about my short deal with
mental illness and homelessness she
loved how much I wore how good I
delivered on everything that I'm an
actors director so she said girl I'm
gonna get you a full feature I was like
uh okay
um I guess that's what we're gonna do
next and she did so it's a full-length
feature um that will be coming out this
October amazing I'm gonna have to keep
an eye out for it thank you thank you of
course of course now I do have to ask
because recently you made some comments
about your love life
um I gotta I gotta
um what do you want
from in the love Department in the
romance Department what are you looking
for I want to partner more than anything
else I want someone that has their own
identity their own career they own money
uh
but more importantly I want somebody
that's going to be fun that likes to
travel that likes to enjoy sports that's
comfortable in their own skin so please
don't be looking for No Sugar Mama and
for me to help you figure out your
identity that's why I say I want them to
you know I'm just I'm looking for a
grown-up to have a fun relationship with
more than anything else
of course you deserve that okay okay
like you said it is my turn you take
care of me you still do things yeah you
know a lot of people what's that new
thing they're looking for their softer
side you know what I mean so it's not so
much me in control and me doing things
I'd like halfway of a softer side
because I still got to have my own
identity and I love working so I just
I'm looking for The Best of Both Worlds
that's why I said a partner and not a
husband or you know what I mean
someone who expects you to take care of
the house now yeah yeah I got that
I love it I love it so I do have one
more question
um do you have any advice for the broke
young black women out here trying to
build a professional life
um that they can be passionate about
this is mostly for me absolutely
um you know what I I tell Young
actresses and you know women that are in
any business do the work
everybody thinks that they can just
swipe to success a career a true career
is built you're going to have UPS you're
going to have Downs be prepared for that
but always keep looking forward and do
the work ciao don't be giving away
everything for free on Instagram and
don't be having the only fans I know
it's quick money but don't do it don't
do it.com do you know what I mean I mean
because it'll come back and haunt you
because nowadays whatever you put out
and I want young girls to know this
whatever you put on the internet
whatever you put there it is forever
logged
uh people can go and find it and you
never know when someone may go and do
background check on you and if you've
done some craziness that is not
um beneficial to their company they'll
hold it against you absolutely no that
makes perfect sense that makes sense I'm
definitely gonna take it to heart thank
you so much you're welcome you're
welcome thank you stay positive and put
your best foot forward you know because
even though you may not get the job that
time people have a tendency to remember
those that left a good impression yeah
that's that's a good thing to live by
too not everything is a failure you know
absolutely
awesome thank you so much was that for
you it was it was most it was entirely
but you know it's good for everybody
else too I want to you know because I'm
here for my people you know
you know so but mostly for me
good good good
well thank you so much um we want to let
everybody know that Saturday July 1st
the interrogation room hosted by your
girl Vivica A fox
you can binge watch all 10 episodes and
it's available on Roku 2B and Amazon
free V awesome film Rises world too yeah